did you take JD Speedo shopping yeah we
sure did hey I'm looking at this picture
JD doesn't look too bad
a little Speedo he doesn't look bad he
looked great you should have seen him
strutting around the store doing Twirls
it was it was you think you're miserable
yeah yeah
JD how did you get him to even go to the
store I asked him nicely and also he
he's always wanted to wear a Speedo he
was a a huge fan of Greg Louganis as a
kid and he told me that I always wanted
to fit it's true so who went to with JD
to get the speedo Chris win and and
blitt you took him I'm a met in the Met
Mike you're in good shape did you see JD
in the speedo did you see the pictures I
saw the pictures yeah he looked good you
look great dude oh stop it it looked
really good I'd like to take Mike Speedo
shopping
this is the body that you wear Speedo
not mine he should have taken off his
shirt that's the number one thing
JD with his Speedo kept his shirt on I
get it but Robin here's uh let me see if
I can show you a picture you see JD and
his Speedo
that's good that's not terrible no I
told you he looks good yeah it's a great
reaction let me see I got some tape here
JD what's funny about this is to hear JD
protesting the whole time getting the
speed off he's just miserable so JD I
guess you were conflicted about wearing
this thing right I mean I mean listen I
I do yeah I want to be a team player
obviously but
I am very uncomfortable with how I look
uh all over and I did not need you know
I just didn't want to wear a Speedo I'm
not a speedo guy here's JD and Blitz
Speedo shopping and JD's even when he
gets to the store he's like I don't know
if I'm gonna wear a speed or not he's
very conflicted here we go hello
this is JD JD nice to meet you silence
JD's always dreamed of wearing us I have
not no I have not dreamed of wearing a
speedo and so today is the day
[Music]
wow yeah I mean this guy it's like every
what he comes up with these stories this
guy he he's turning to Greg Louganis
look like Greg Louganis all the time I
even dreamed of being like Greg Louganis
ever dude you've told me this
dude yeah this is what I'm dealing with
I had never told him you have but you
were over here at my place you were at
dinner at my place you're like you know
what John I've I used to watch Greg
Louganis as a kid and I've always
dreamed of wearing that kind of swimsuit
I wouldn't [__] make this up JD and I
take offense to it
I believe you John yeah
I got I got that and then I got him
[__] backing him off and
has a technique with JD he's good with
JD he eases him into wearing the speedo
okay he had JD trying a pair of a tight
tiny lace-up swim shorts the ones you
just saw Robin and uh okay so here's JD
in the dressing room trying these on so
you get a sense of what's going on oh my
you gotta be [__] kidding me you
gotta come out you gotta be kidding me
oh my God
if I like adjust these things like just
a little bit my ball pops out
my balls are hanging out because they're
huge good God stuff them in there honey
all right are we coming are we are you
ready yeah we're ready three I'm gonna
do it okay yeah yeah the store has a
rule Robin that when you try on bathing
suits you must wear your underwear
underneath because you know people have
[__] you know
JD didn't wear his underwear he broke
the road underwear either you told me
not to oh see hey yeah it's true he's
like John I need that you did you said
the only way to feel a speedo I've
always wanted to feel without underwear
and I was doing what you said you were a
raw dog in the underwear yeah well
anyway uh JD finally agreed to try on a
tiny black Speedo
and then he had trouble getting it on
why are we having so much trouble with
the tiny black oh I think this is this
the one where I didn't untie it first
yeah I didn't I didn't realize there
were strings or whatever it's his first
time all right all right here we go JD
can you explain the outfit that you've
just walked into the dressing room with
it it's [__] panties it looks like
panties
and don't you know feminize it because
of it that's right
this one is amazing I might be having a
little bit of fun Jamie not really yeah
he is oh this this isn't fitting I'm not
putting it on it's not fitting at all is
this the smallest
um bathing suit you've ever worn yeah I
can't I lit I cannot put this one on
yeah you can no I can't you can trust me
what where is it getting stuck where is
this hold on hold on hold on yeah
no the whole relationship is JD yelling
and blue telling you can do it you can
do it you know
when I first walked into this door he
was so adamant that he was not doing
this and the next thing I know he's in
the dressing room
blitz good with you he gets you to do
stuff oh yeah yeah so you went down to
the beach right and uh what happened
yeah we went down to the beach we did
some exercising JD did like fashion
shows around the the speedo shop which
was fantastic and he really became one
with the speedo and he loved being in it
and wow
now he didn't take off his shirt though
right was it was that awkward for me yes
I would have loved him to be totally
free but you know you take steps baby
steps he looked like Winnie the Pooh you
know Winnie the Pooh as the the top on
and no pants
but JD's got a big package I think he's
got I always suspect that he had a big
[__] and I think what he has is really
big balls because I think they kept
popping out of the speedo and at one
point I looked down and I could see like
it looked like two things were dangling
I think those were his balls shaft is
huge too though it's like an elephant's
truck yeah look at all the fun
I was Miami Hospital
[Applause]
you already know what happens in Miami
never happened
foreign